to Madison Wisconsin and just down the
road for me was a small pot and I spent
a lot of my time on that small time and
one of the great things about my job now
is I get to spend a lot of time on
larger cons so I've done research in
Africa which I'll talk to you about
today New Mexico Wisconsin New York
Sweden I've been to the Antarctic and so
one of the great things about my career
has been being able to travel all these
really interesting places today I want
to take you to the Serengeti the
Serengeti is located here on the border
of Kenya and Tanzania in East Africa I
want to take you into the Serengeti talk
mostly about the work that we do here in
the Masai Mara reserve in Kenya as the
Mara River flows from Kenya into
Tanzania into Lake Victoria what I'm
going to talk about are these large
animal communities in Africa and I'm
going to take you to Africa because this
is one of the few remaining places in
the world where these large animal
communities are still mostly intact so
there are not large number these large
body vertebrates like hippos and
wildebeests that I'm going to talk to
you about today and we won't understand
their role in these ecosystems now if we
go back to North America even just a few
thousand years ago you would have found
large bodied animals like this all over
the place many of them have been
displaced and we're going to Africa
trying to understand what role they have
in that
the ecosystem so I'm going to take you
to the Masai Mara National Reserve was
established in 1961 it's about 600
square miles it's located in Kenya it's
a great place to do research because as
you doing research you have things like
giraffes wandering around the landscape
and lions you get to fly in to remote
locations and we set up our research in
fairly remote and interesting places and
I'll show you a bit of the challenge of
working in a place like Kenya as I talk
about our research so I'm going to talk
about the Mara River the Mara River is a
large trans boundary river it flows from
Kenya through Tanzania into Lake
Victoria it is about 7% of the flow of
water into Lake Victoria so some of you
might know like victoria is a very big
lake and the Mara River is an important
part of the watershed of Lake Victoria
it is an unregulated River that means
it's a river without any dams there's no
control of its flow so it will get very
big at times of the year and it will get
very small at time to the year and
that's part of the story is how that
flow that discharge of the river goes up
and down as a big impact there's also
the only constant source of water in the
region it's called the lifeblood of the
Serengeti because it provides a
permanent source of water for all the
animals that live there here's a a
family of elephants drinking from the
Mara River that's a pretty common
sighting sevres elephants wildebeest
lots of animals come down
tomorrow for their water oh the
questions that I want to address today
on how to do large animals they live in
the Mahr influence the ecology of this
river and the two animals of our group
focuses on our hippos and wildebeest
okay and we're going to focus on these
two animals because hippos spend a lot
of their time in the water and
wildebeest cross the Mara River
repeatedly during their migration those
are the two things I'm going to talk to
you about here's the research team so my
graduate students Kristen Amanda they're
actually in the back with their new
daughter named Amanda so Chris Amanda
and I are all here you know University
stuff here we are and the Mara along
with our collaborator rosie Marshall
from the Kerry Institute research
institute in upstate New York called Amy
right here is a local guide and research
assistant of ours in Kenya we started
this work back in 2011 Chris and Amanda
had been in Kenya for a few years before
coming to grad school where they were
doing work for the USAID flow and land
use of human impacts on the Mara River
and they brought those contacts in those
local experts eat that local expertise
into my lab so that we could conduct
this research
so here's Amanda of working in Kenya as
a challenging and an interesting
experience so many of us here at Yale
work in labs like this building and we
spend a lot of our time in the lab in
Kenya it's a little bit different we
don't have a portable lab but we do have
a portable
actually so here's a man interests in
our portable bow and a field camp in
Kenya that we keep permanently here's
Chris and me we're doing some work out
of the back of our Land Rover we'll stop
take a lunch break and do research right
anywhere we happen to be and here's an
experimental stream setup that we've
deployed I'll talk about a little while
and a water user a resource water user
on location in Kenya okay so we we kind
of take advantage of the infrastructure
wherever we can find it and sometimes
that's just the back of our research
vehicle okay so I want to talk first
about migrating wildebeest
so here wildebeest wildebeest are really
fascinating because they make one of the
last remaining over land migrations one
of the last remaining great overland
migrations that the earth has right now
they use the entire Serengeti ecosystem
they spend much of December through May
June July and August down here in
Tanzania where the grass is tall and
they will follow the rains and the tall
grass up into Kenya low migrate up in
Dickon Kenya and then back down each
year so they make this large mass
migration each year the population of
wildebeest is quite high right now and
that was not historically true so there
is a disease rinderpest
that wiped out most of the wildebeest in
this part of the world it was a disease
that moved between cattle and other or
calm animals like wildebeest they move
the diseases move between those wildlife
and cattle eradication efforts began in
the 1950s and early 60s and it is one of
two viruses that have been
while worldwide at this point once
rentapen rinderpest was eliminated from
the wildebeest population you could see
the numbers increase very quickly and
now the population stable somewhere
between about a million and a million
and a half wildebeest at any point in
time okay and that's where it's been now
for about thirty years you don't have
much data past 2000 this is a herd of
wildebeest it's a mixture you'll see
some zebras in here but these wildebeest
and these zebras will migrate from
Tanzania and dekenia every year during
this migration a large number of them
will die about a quarter of the
wildebeest each year die during this
migration so we estimate that maybe a
quarter of a million wildebeest die each
year much of that is predation so here
we have Lions taking down trying to take
down the wildebeest pretty common sight
during migration they're an important
resource for many of the Predators of
the city during the migration but they
also cross the Mara River up here in
Kenya and they'll do multiple crossings
of this river going back and forth
looking for tall grass good grass for
them to eat and some of those wildebeest
died during the crossing of the Mara so
here we have a small number of
wildebeest crossing the Mara River
and is that mortality those willoughby's
that die that we're interested in we're
interested in what is the effect of that
mortality of those dying will to be on
the river itself okay so here we have a
fairly typical crossing of wildebeest we
have a large herd of wildebeest
wildebeest are not well known to be
particularly smart animals okay they are
also not strong swimmers so you can see
where I'm headed with this right so we
have wildebeest crossing the river in
large numbers if the river is high or
the place where they're trying
exit the river is very steep they'll
start to pile up in large numbers so you
will have tens of thousands of
wildebeest crossing the river repeatedly
and as they start to pile up on the
shoreline they start to panic okay so
this is my my trigger warning here the
next couple slides are gonna be a bit
graphic and at that point they start to
drown in very large numbers okay so here
we have a large number of wildebeest
carcasses that have drowned trying to
cross the river so this is actually if
you want to think about in terms of the
circle of life really important part of
what goes on in our ecosystem because
now you will have hundreds sometimes
thousands of wildebeest carcass is
sitting in the river and they attract
scavengers from the entire region so we
will now have hundreds and thousands of
birds scavengers like these men all new
storks flying in from across the region
to feed on those carcasses you'll also
have crocodiles and we have occasionally
seen 50 60 70 sometimes upwards of a
hundred crocodiles converging on these
mass mortality events these drowning
events to forage on is dead wildebeest
and in fact there's so many wildebeests
that died in some of these that the
crocodiles are now fully full and
ignoring the rest of the carcasses
there right so this is one of the big
questions what happens to those
carcasses where do they go what impact
they have on the river these are natural
events we know that these drowning
events have been happening for as long
as there have been wildebeest crossing
the Mara River they happen all the time
sometimes you'll see videos of a
crocodile reaching up and grabbing a
zebra or a wildebeest that's very common
event but not nearly as many animals die
by crocodiles getting them as ground
when they cross the river okay well we
go counting the number of drowning
events and the number of wildebeests
that die in each event since 2011 so we
have about more years of data now this
basically means we walk the entire
length of the river after a drowning
event and count every single carcass it
is exactly as fun as it sounds
so here are Amanda and I County
carcasses along a stretch of the Mara
River we estimate that there are at
least five drowning events every year
those range in size from a couple
hundred movies up to a few thousand and
every year on average we're seeing about
seven thousand movies die crossing the
Mara River in the area that we do our
research there are some other areas that
we don't study so the numbers are higher
but not much higher this is one of the
major crossing areas for movies oh so
we've pulled some carcasses out of the
water to try to understand what makes up
a wildebeest if we want to know where
ends up and how it affects the river we
need to understand how much carbon
nitrogen and bone and other things are
in the carcass of each carcass weight is
about 175 kilograms so these are fairly
large animals and we estimated that
these seven pounds of Willoughby's put
in about 12,000 tons of biomass every
year so it's a large amount
of animal material that's going into the
river every year from these implements
so we've pulled some wildebeest side of
the river after drowning event and if we
were working on a really small fish or
something else we might be able to
figure out its chemical composition just
by taking the whole fish it's a little
hard to do with the wildebeest so we
have to actually dissect wildebeest into
all of its component parts and then look
at the chemical compositions of all of
those parts so a wildebeest is mostly
bone and a lot of muscle and things like
heart and stomach contacts right that's
what sort of makes up a wildebeest we
can take that apart and then we can put
a wildebeest back together and ask as it
breaks down what's happening to it so we
know that these will be these these
carcasses are adding about 121 tons of
carbon 28 tonnes of nitrogen and 14.3
tonnes of phosphorus into the river
every year now it's nice you're getting
phosphorus that really drives things
like the growth of algae and other
plants in a river so these are important
parts of the ecosystem that we want to
understand and carbon is really
important for a lot of bacteria in water
a lot of bacteria will use that carbon
as an energy source
well where did those carcasses go what
happens to them well so a lot of the
wildebeest bone you know think about
your own body a lot of movie what makes
you up his bone in fact most of the
phosphorus in vertebrates like
wildebeest and my boss is tied up the
bone that bows not going anywhere right
so that bone doesn't break down very
fast so we're gonna set that aside for a
moment it's in the river and it's
you know there were very long period of
time we're gonna ignore it for a minute
and then there's the soft tissue that's
the tissue in a wildebeest that it's
going to be eaten by all the scavengers
that's gonna get broken down very
quickly we actually can estimate how
much the scavengers are eating and how
much they're taking back to the land ok
so it's just a few percent of what goes
in is that key being taken back to this
Arrietty by scavengers like these birds
mouth with storms and some of us being
eaten in stream and we can't estimate
that right now we actually don't have
the ability to pull crocodiles and out
of the marsh and we asked them how much
they eat at this point we're working on
that we're not there yet and then a lot
of the material gets transported down
the river or taken up by things like
algae and bacteria that eventually feed
the fish in the Mara River so that's
where a lot of it goes this is a video
from a game camera we've put the cameras
out on some of these carcass
piles they ask what's going on that was
day we're at night now
and here's day again and during this
night it rained the next day there were
no carcasses yeah so what you saw there
were just hundreds if not thousands of
scavengers coming into these carcasses
and ripping apart feeding off of them
and then dispersing again when those
carcasses washed downstream that's a
very common occurrence for these mass
mortality events okay so that's what
happens to these carcasses and we're
still working on this we've only
working on these questions for a couple
years we don't know the full fate and
impacts yeah the carcasses but we know a
little bit about the causing act of the
causes at this point there are three
things we think are really important for
causing these mortality events what is
high water when the moderate river is
low and there's a drought in the region
the wildebeests just walked right across
the river that there's no problem
there's no swimming they're not going to
have any mortality geomorphology is a
fancy word for how steep the slope is
okay so how steep the side of the river
is where the exit seems to play an
important role so when their exit is
very narrow and the slope is very steep
and there are large numbers of them
crossing and that seems to any feed when
we get the largest mortality events
there's also some indication that human
behavior particularly tourists who come
in to see these crossings might be
changing the behavior and the location
of the crossing of these wildebeest and
that that might be having an impact
along with high water the geomorphology
for these mortality events but this is
where we're trying to what other things
we're trying to piece apart understand
right now okay there are the effects on
the wildebeest population I saw poorer
in some of your eyes when I talked about
all of these wildebeest dying but it's
just a couple percent of the wildebeest
that would have died anyway on this
migration there's not much impact on the
wildebeest of these drought events but
there are really really big impacts on
the river okay so having 7,000
wildebeest carcasses in a river means
that there's an enormous amount of
carbon and nutrients being put into the
river and changing the food web
structure it's having an impact on the
scavengers and it's probably changing
food web structures so these types of
fish
in there and things that they eat are
probably changing and that's the work
that we're still working on right now
but we do know that it changes the way
think nutrients like carbon nitrogen and
phosphorus cycle through the river and
but that this only happens for a short
period of time these migrations are
seasonal the will to be starting
tomorrow crossing the Mara River for
only a month or two of each year and so
these are short-term inputs into the
river well you might be asking yourself
how common is this is this something
that only happens in the Mara and the
answer is no we know that carcass inputs
are a very common event in aquatic
ecosystem so acidic salmon are well
known to move a lot of marine nutrients
in to rivers in the Pacific Northwest we
know that caribou and bison cross rivers
and often drown during those crossings
Whale fall in the ocean is a really
important source of nutrients to
communities that live on the bottom of
the ocean and we know from historical
from paleo records that mammoths and
even dinosaurs often died very large
numbers in aquatic systems indeed that's
where we get the bones and the remains
for many dinosaurs and many things like
mammoths and mastodons and in terms of
how widespread this happens either
events that would have happened or do
happen all over the world so things like
Pacific salmon all around the Pacific
Basin are common inputs of nutrients in
the aquatic system bison when they
roamed North America and the millions
would have contributed a lot of
nutrients to rivers like the Mississippi
and the Missouri and other large rivers
completely last and we have things like
wildebeest here in Africa that used to
be very widespread but are still very
abundant in certain parts of Africa okay
so that's the wildebeest or you give us
who likes hippos
okay how many of you think hippos are
really really cute and you want to have
one okay we got one tanker okay well I'm
gonna I'm gonna try and persuade you
that that's probably not the answer you
want okay so anyone know the closest
group living relatives of hippos ya know
what nope nope crocodile oh not rhinos
whales so the closest trip living
relative evolutionarily to the hippo are
cetacean whales and dolphins okay ah
forty million years ago fifty million
years ago these blips Oh
hippos did not look nearly like hippos
do today forty million years ago right
and neither did many of these two
patients but where's your closest living
relatives if those are pretty odd for
land animals that way they are very
widespread they were historically very
widespread in Africa but actually some
subspecies of hippos the remains of some
speed subspecies of hippos have been
found all throughout Europe fact there's
some they've been found in England
before the last glaciation so hippos
used to be very widespread they're
restricted to just most of these green
areas in Africa today but they were very
widespread in sub-saharan Africa
historically of during the day hippos
spend most of their time in water okay
so here we have hippos and water lots
and lots of hippos in the water hippos
in water and just along the side of the
shoreline okay so when you go looking
for hippos during the day in Kenya
find them right on the shoreline or in
the water in very large groups they tend
to be in large herds of 10 20 upwards of
a hundred hippos sitting in pools in the
Mara River at night they get up and out
of the water and they typically go out
and eat grass now there are some reports
of hippos eating meat but mostly they're
eating grass okay there you go so that's
true so the grass thing does not have a
lot of nutrients so they have to eat an
enormous amount of it but what they do
the next days they go back to the water
where they sleep in rash and of course
thing
so they excrete an enormous amount of
grass into the water bodies during the
day they do some of that on land also
okay so NASA's question earlier about
wanting a petit fo nipples are very
dangerous animals okay so one of the
challenges about working
remote location the others we're working
with animals that can be very dangerous
so hippos and crocodiles are very
dangerous animals they can have most of
the water they are very territorial
in fact the male's will kill other males
they fight they will also kill crocodile
did they battle with really big tusks
and they fight their mouths oh they're
actually people would go to these
typical and survey them and collect data
force development works they have a will
almost any other type
imagine it so we had to be temperature
dissolved oxygen monitor we're actually
very concerned that a crocodile or told
me to store the phone while other than a
pool we have some aside for the bars how
he disguised it and the X instead of me
disguised that a crocodile that a hippo
probably would not bother and thankfully
he was right the hippo probably would
not bother and think we he was right
never attacked by the hippler Procter
experience in college but there was no
gracious way to put it all this is great
because we've got a lot of great data
from both so working with hippos is just
one of the challenges as you see there
also crocodiles another thing so this
boat has allowed us to go into places
where we normally couldn't go that so
when I work in lakes here in Connecticut
I take a rowboat out I can get into the
water I don't have to worry about much
of anything except in the case dome Swan
or snapping turtle
of course working a little different
you'll see that boat show up again okay
big question we have is how much to
hippos extreme okay they're out in the
grasslands all day they come back to the
water all night they come back to the
water during the day and they're
screening so one of the challenges we
don't have the ability to take a hippo
and put it in a small aquarium you can
do that with fish and other things but I
can't do that with a hippo I know you'd
like one but I'm telling you you don't
have a room they're not forever but
there are some places where the group is
big enough one of them is the Milwaukee
zoo walky zoo has hippos and they were
generous enough to allow us to go to the
zoo and clean out the tank that they use
for hippos and look at how much hippos
extreme use this one a lot of other
literature to try and understand what it
was
do i okay so here's the pool nice and
clean right let the hippos in
doesn't walk so that that gave us the
ability to ask how much nitrogen and
carbon and other stuff was in the water
when it was clean and how much was in
that water when it got dirty 24 hours
later now one of the problems with this
is that we knew what was in the water
but when it hit those who they move out
a lot of very heavy undigested grass
that goes to the bottom
so unfortunately Amanda had to climb in
and sweep it out okay but now that you
have a bunch of hippo eats and how much
it excretes and all of that can be put
into models and we can ask what happens
so we know that each info needs about
the big tons of grass each year they eat
a lot of grass because it's not very
good food right oh that means that they
are eating the population of hippos that
we study in the Mara River they eat
somewhere between about 300 and 1,500
hectares of grass every year okay that
is equivalent to somewhere between 2 and
11 times the entire Yale campus okay
they're eating that much grass and they
have enough productive how much there is
out there and about half of that is
ending up in the river about half of
that ends of the river so is one day one
day is about 3,200 kilograms of carbon
put into the river each day by hippos
that is the equivalent of one and a half
don't trucks of carbon just being dumped
into the river every day over a week
that would be about 11 dump trucks worth
of carbon the material is being dumped
into the river by hippos and they're
doing that every day all year round and
what they do so we call that a conveyor
belt we call this the hippopotamus
conveyor belt so they move carbon and
the Mara River every day all year round
next question we want to ask is that
they've given that they're moving all of
this material into the river what impact
does that have on them what happens to
the river right okay so here's the
region we work out here's the Mara River
Basin it flows through the Masai Mara
the Serengeti and into Lake Victoria
here we have a region where we have a
couple stations where we have automated
equipment outlets measuring water
quality constantly through time okay one
of them up here is above where all the
hippos reside in the Masai Mara and
another one right here on the Tanzanian
Kenyan border sits below these 4,000 to
5,000 M oh so we can measure the water
above the hippos and the water flowing
good the river below okay so this is the
amount of dissolved oxygen in the water
it's the percent of the amount of oxygen
that the water can carry okay so this is
the site up above the hippos nearly a
hundred percent of oxygen is saturated
there's almost a hundred percent of the
oxygen that the water can carry and this
is a site down below that but you can
see that there's less oxygen down there
probably because these hippos are
enormous amount of carbon into the river
you can almost see a couple other
features here you get this big drop in
dissolved oxygen at times here that
became really interesting because big
rivers are never supposed to have these
kinds of big drops because there's a
constant movement of air into the river
as it flows okay here's another part of
our data set we have these dry period
here and then these spikes this is the
height of the river technology this was
an unregulated river so it can be very
low it can be very high and then loves
these are wringing events happening in
the watershed and then that Brandon
happens the water level comes up very
quickly and then it starts to go back
down but we know this on some of these
rain events that after a long dry period
right here these first few rain events
we got very very little oxygen in the
river again you're not supposed to get
low oxygen in big rivers this doesn't
happen in most places the world and
these are very low amounts of oxygen
really close to zero oxygen in the water
column well we happen to have some good
analyses that going during a couple of
these events one of them is we were
measuring how much kip-up
feces we're going down the river during
one of these events were dissolved
oxygen extraction so what we were able
to show measures that there are
somewhere between sixty and eighty
thousand kilograms of hippo material
when we moved through the river each
hour during one of these flushing enough
one of these rain events dang so there's
a lot of hippo material undigested grass
metier
we also started noticing dead fish we
start noticing dead fish now if you know
anything about fish fish need oxygen
most fish need carry large amounts of
oxygen to live in aquatic systems so
oxygen is getting close to zero these
fish are gonna have a hard time
surviving and some of the fish we had
gills that were completely clogged with
sediment today so they were just being
suffocated by all the sediment in the
water in others the deals looked really
clean so that means they're dying from
something else maybe talks of something
toxic like the a lack of water or lack
of water lack of oxygen and other things
that might be in the water okay so
here's what we think is happening so if
it was like pools and you usually don't
just get one hippo in a pool oh well if
you have one hippo on the pool it's
gonna excrete that grass into the body
and some of its going to flow down the
river but you don't generally just get
one hippo you get a whole bunch of
hippos and with a whole bunch of hippos
you can get a lot of grass undigested
grass going to the bottom and some of it
going down the river as the river starts
to get lower as the flow starts to get
lower you can concentrate that but you
also bring in a lot more hippos to these
pools in fact you will get really really
large groups of hippos in these pool
that low water because there's not much
of anywhere else for them to go
that means you now have an even more
undigested grass going into the bottom
of these pools they hit their excreting
and again some of its still going down
the street well now we get a rain event
in the watershed what happens well the
water starts to go up you have all of
that partially digested hippo
in the bottom of the pool and it now
gets washed out by the flood event okay
as that happens all of that starts to
create this low oxygen event of the
river downstream meeting the fish killer
okay so this is our hypothesis this is
what we think is going on at the Mara
River okay so we call this the hippo
pool hypothesis that during periods of
low flow organic material settles and
concentrates on the bottom of these cool
so this is like a compost pile right or
a sewage treatment plant for hippos
during the first flood after a period of
low flow though that water then picks
that material up and flushes it down the
river
I don't like flushing the toilet right
so we have this larger flushing event
that results in a drop of dissolved
oxygen and likely creates these fish
gills okay so this is our hypothesis
it's consistent with what we see in the
Mara River how do we test this well we
have access to hippo poop this is hippo
poop right here that Amanda is
collecting dissertation so we can also
collect the water that's at the bottom
of the hippo pool so Chris has the fun
job this time Chris is pumping up the
water you can see the surface is brown
but the block bottom is jet black this
is just really rich organic material as
at the bottom pools we can take that
material and put them into experiments
and we can ask what are the effect
isolated from all the other things so
here's an experimental screen I'll just
show you how these work these streams
have a motor they have a motor that
turns these paddle wheels that gives us
flow today we have about 60 80 liters of
water in each of these and we can do
experiments in these streams we can keep
the flow going and we can look at things
like how insects might live in there we
can look at things like how much oxygen
is consumed so we think but putting
these streams together in North America
would be fairly straightforward in fact
they're there in extreme facilities all
over North America but in Kenyans have
been in the challenge that so putting
these dreams together started with some
work with master seamstress see who sews
tents who made those dreams it spent a
lot of time at Harry's hardware store in
Nara where we had to get all sorts of
things and people would get out here and
kind of crazy and we asked for certain
things and working with a master welder
can create these paddle wheels that we
then loaded up and took to our field
site so there are constant challenges
working in a place like Kenya it's also
fairly easy working in Kenya because
there are truly remarkable people with
incredible skills and then willing to
work
these crazy scientific projects we do
okay so we took Blackwater here's Chris
adding black waters and streams and we
kicked a hippo poop and we've added that
to the stream that we've done a whole
series of experiments using this
material that hippos load is tomorrow
River they have to wonder the effects
okay so what are the effects well the
first the biggest strongest effect we
see is that all of this material reduces
the amount of oxygen in the water okay
so what's happening here is that the
hippo poop and the black water which is
the product of a lot of working microbes
and other things working on that info
booth creates a huge amount of oxygen
demand okay so that carbon in there is a
source of energy and bacteria are using
it and they're consuming oxygen okay
so there's a large amount of what we
call biological oxygen demand
there's also chemical oxygen demand that
some of the chemicals that be produced
so he doesn't minute consume oxygen also
they're also contributing an enormous
amount of nutrients to the rivers so
that is also toxic at high levels okay
so we think this is what's happening
because those fish kills well this is
great because it's happening in 660
liters of water but what about in big
natural systems right so I've shown you
the pattern and tomorrow some
experiments we've done but let's find
something a little bit in between that's
a little challenging since we know that
most of the ponds in the Mara have
crocodiles and hippos they're hardly
working so we went to a pond where we
knew there
okay and what we did is we built the dam
so this is the body bottom pond we built
a dam right here and we pulled up water
behind that dam so that we could flush
the pool experimental okay so the first
experiment we did is we sample in a
variety of places here in the pool down
the street and I'll show you a bit of
that data and then a variety of other
places on this river we built a dam
we've created a pool and then we release
all that water very quickly like a rain
event so it's not a true rain event but
it supplies close as we can get okay we
did that without any hippos stuff in
there okay just see what happen when we
cross the pool then we rented a water
lorry that brought in an enormous amount
of water drawn from the bottom of the
hippo pool and we added that over two
days so we added a huge amount of cold
water okay into this pond then we
question again okay so this is the
closest we can get to an ecosystem a
whole ecosystem experiment to test this
idea this flushing a hippo pool might
cause these low oxygen events and kill
fish okay so here's what it looks like a
little pumping in the hippo water so
lots of black water going into this pool
so big changes of this pool okay right
away that was interesting
then we went upstream and we added a
conservative tracer a dye that has no
effect on anything and that's a way that
we can trace where the water is coming
from Thanks see how it's mixing we mix
that all up we have this big pool above
here now and then we let it go
release all that water through the
system
okay so we created this question event
just like we didn't I pop the size and
now we're expecting when there's hippo
hoop in the pool that the oxygen should
fall downstream there's no Bigfoot in
the pool we don't know what's gonna
happen then we haven't seen that but we
expected that not to happen okay
so first thing we had to do is run
downstream in fact live up there
releasing the water Chris Amanda gave E
and M overall downstream doing this this
is two minutes later sampling water
France read the numbers one in oil we're
down there randomly sampling and from
this head of data there's kind of
sampling we can then start to ask what
happened to the ecosystem now below this
so here we are this is the amount of
dissolved oxygen this is exactly the
same kind of major I showed you from the
Mara River a few slides before here's
the control the salt oxygen was up
around 9 milligrams per liter it fell a
little bit when we flushed it okay so
that seems to be what happens when you
flush a tool that doesn't have then we
loaded a lot of hippo Fugen right so
this was something like where we think a
couple hundred hippos for a couple days
equivalent of nutrients being put into
the pool
well the first thing you notice is
dissolved oxygen is actually higher what
we think happened is all those nutrients
we put into the pool some of that we're
flushing
down there the days that we're learning
then stimulating algae and that algae is
producing a lot of oxygen detectors like
huge blooms of algae downstream so some
nutrients are really good for these
systems okay but then when you flush all
the nutrients out it caused a really big
decline in dissolved oxygen okay
so watching a typical just from a couple
days where the hippo food has a big
impact on the amount of oxygen water
column and we could measure that
biological oxygen demand and here it
falls in the control flushing but it
goes it's really high and stays high
once we have flushed the pool that has
all that dip okay so now we have
experimental evidence that is consistent
with our small-scale experiments and our
whole are measurements that we have okay
okay so right now we're using our
robotic boat that cannot robot we have
little joystick so it's a remote control
boat to survey a whole bunch of pawns
that ffos in them so we did that last
year we'll do some more of that we're
trying to analyze that data to
understand what happens in natural ponds
but one of the things we know from this
kind of experiment if we went back to
that hippo pool where we got the black
water from the enormous amount of
methane in that water okay so this is
the amount of methane in the bottom of
water of a hippo pool this is the lethal
dose for 50% mortality for fish that the
EPA has done for many many fish species
for methane well there's a lot of
methane in the water in the bottom of
these pools and it's at a level that
would be lethal to most fish same thing
for ammonia so this is nitrogen a form
of nitrogen really high levels of
ammonia much higher than the EPA's acute
maximum so this would kill all fish in
one hour or cause death in one day or
cause harm to fish so really really high
levels of nutrients in their byproducts
at the water this is hydrogen sulfide
I'm consulting a pretty toxic chemical
this is the acute mortality for
nine fish species down here around 80
micrograms per liter we're getting well
over 800 the bottomless water okay so
this is what's being flushed out of a
hippo pool during the day flushing
effects and this is one of the things
that consume all the oxygen and we think
is causing these fish kills so again
we're going into these systems with the
boat working our way around
hippos which are territorial come and do
not like the boat all that much and try
them now understand how this plays out
in natural systems through the season
okay so these hippos are acting as a
conveyor belt they are out there at
night eating the larvae so mama grass
they move about half of what they eat
into the Mara River and a lot of that
accumulates in the sediments at low
rates of loading probably beneficial
these are added nutrients into the water
that are good that are growing more
algae growing more fish but at really
high densities of hippos and really high
concentration all of us get both of all
of this excretion is having potentially
detrimental effects on the water in the
Mara River one of the things we don't
really fully understand right now what's
breaking down all that grass that's
going in
we don't know if this might be the same
bacteria that lives in a hippo gut it
might be that the bottom of these pool
are not all together different than
what's going on in the hippo cat we
starting to do some work on that right
now okay so we summarized this gun
Africa we've gone to Africa because
we're interested in these large animals
the role that I play in the aquatic
ecosystems one of the things I haven't
talked about is that we have hippos
excreting a lot of nutrients of the
water in the same place that we have
these wildebeest diet so one of the
questions we're working on right now is
trying to understand those interactions
we've got a little bit of experimental
work on that and we'll do some more in
the next few years
oh we're working on how these inputs
influence Tamar River Food Bank so we
haven't talked much about how impact the
small insects and the fish that live in
the water but we're just starting to
work on that we've quantified how much
it's going in and some of its effects
we've not want to see where does it end
up is that info grass that hippo poop
ending up in this tilapia or in this
invertebrate here we don't know yet oh
and what is the role these scavengers
right so we have this really interesting
dynamic when when you get a large number
of will these dying these scavengers
come in from all over the place so we
have a high school students just
starting to ask questions about the role
of different scavengers as they come in
to and colonize these hippo are these
wildebeest drowning events and where
that might end up so we know about these
storks and crocodiles are important but
we also see things like hyenas coming in
they might be eating the bones
they're very well known
chewing up bones we might can see other
animals and invertebrate insects that
colonize these where we have a sample
down okay and finally all this is
happening with the end of conservation
and management concepts there's a lot of
land-use change going on in Kenya right
now Kenya is a growing economy there's
an enormous amount of cattle grazing by
the Masai a lot of land-use change by up
in the watershed and there's water look
for all going on to the Mara River three
their proposals are dams and roads to
cross through this area all of which
would change things like migratory
patterns and the flow discharge of the
river so trying to tie a research back
into the larger social economic issues
or something that we're working on right
now okay so none of this work could have
been done without a Norma's amount of
time and effort support we've had
support from Yale University National
Science Foundation National Geographic
Society and a Switzer Foundation grant
to one of my graduate students we also
have incredibly good local partners you
cannot be work like this without local
partners the big ones we have
collaborators at the National Museums of
Kenya the World Wildlife Fund and the
Mara Conservancy group which oversees
the conservation and management of a
large part of the Mara but it's even
more than that Chris and Amanda when
they were in Kenya before they came to
Yale created a number of partnerships
watch shelters with watershed
associations and we have relied on that
for support when the Land Rover breaks
down for access to water electricity and
things like that this is truly a
remarkable place to do research because
the partners are really strong and
really what we do and with that I'd like
to thank you for your kind